We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P.
Here is a a comment about the
recent mass shootings and Joe Biden.
Hey, David. Jerry calling from San Antonio. Right.
I was just curious, how long do you think it'll
be before the 21 year old Syrian born shooter
mass shooting in Colorado killed? Ten people
will be blamed on Joe Biden's airstrikes in Syria.
I haven't heard it blamed on Biden's Syrian air
strikes yet. Doesn't mean it won't be. But I
have already seen Biden wanting to take guns,
is responsible for the shootings. And I don't
even I didn't even maybe I'm too stupid.
Maybe the problem is me. I didn't understand the
connection, but I saw that Biden's anti-gun agenda
is to blame for the shootings also, since so
so right wing media already was under covering
the shooting in Georgia because it was a white
perpetrator who killed Asian people. A lot of
the right wing networks ignored that altogether or
barely mentioned it. Now that we know the shooter
in Colorado is Muslim, right wing network networks
are going absolutely, completely bonkers, falling
over themselves to talk about that while still
barely mentioning the one from two days before. So
everybody is doing exactly what we would expect
them to do. Maybe the Syrian airstrikes will be
pointed to as the reason why this shooting
took place, although I haven't heard it yet.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Oakland
is launching a guaranteed pay plan for low income
people. Very interesting idea. The South
Dakota governor is trying to block trans
athletes from women's sports, not just in South
Dakota, but nationally. How we'll explain it.
And unfortunately, roads are getting deadlier for
pedestrians. It's not just drivers who are seeing
an increased rate of fatalities over the last
year. It is also pedestrians. And we will talk
about that on today's bonus show as well. How do
you get the bonus show? Really easy. Go to join
Pakman dot com and sign up. That's it. Go to join
Pakman dot com and sign up. You'll get instant
access to the membership benefits, which include
commercial free audio and video streams of the
show, as well as the Daily Bonus Show. You can
use the coupon code better. Twenty one. If you
want a discount, don't feel obligated. And you
can also get bonus show access by becoming a
patron at Patreon dot com slash David Pakman
show. I will see you then. We're back tomorrow.
We're back Friday. Then we are off for a
week. Just a reminder will be off next week.